THAT BRINGS THE TOTAL NUMBER
ARRESTED TO 17.
>> IN THE MEANTIME, WANT TO SHOW
YOU A PICTURE OF ARIANA GRANDE.
SHE'S ALREADY BACK IN THE CITY
THIS WEEKEND AND THIS IS LESS
THAN TWO WEEKS AFTER THE TERROR
ATTACK AT HER CONCERT.
WE LOOK AT THAT.
SHE WAS AT A HOSPITAL, THE GIRL
SHE'S HUGGING IS 8-YEAR-OLD LILY
H
HARRISON, SHE'S RECOVERING FROM
INJURIES SUSTAINED AT THE
CONCERT.
HER MOM SAYS SHE SAT ON THE
HOSPITAL BED, TOLD LILY SHE WAS
PROUD OF HER, AND SAYS HER VISIT
HAS SHOWN THE KINDNESS OF PEOPLE
RATHER THAN HATE.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT WHERE THAT
GIRL WAS TWO WEEKS AGO, WHERE
SHE IS NOW, SITTING WITH ARIANA
GRANDE, IMAGINE THE IMPACT THAT
WILL HAVE ON HER.
>> LOOK AT SOME OF THE FACES ON
THE SCREEN.
PUT THEM UP.
ACTS LIKE KATY PERRY, MILEY
CYRUS, JUSTIN BEIBER, USHER,
PHARRELL.
THEY WILL JOIN ARIANA GRANDE FOR
A TRIBUTE CONCERT TOMORRO